tiré à mot bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors vous
êtes signataires de cette tribune
qu'est ce qui vous gêne dans les
méthodes du gouvernement bien le
problème c'est la généralisation dans la
vie quotidienne de ce pass sanitaire qui
apporte un faux sentiment de sécurité le
reportage que vous venez passer une
excellente illustration de la situation
dans les lieux clos
il faut conserver les mesures barrières
et en particulier le masque
c'est pas parce que vous êtes vacciné
eux ou que vous avez une pcr de moins de
48 heures qu'il faut enlever le masque
dans les lieux clos le variant indien
est particulièrement contagieux
donc il faut continuer à appliquer ces
mesures barrières dans l'est du clos
site indispensable et on a jugé
totalement irresponsable de la part du
gouvernement de publier au journal
officiel du 20 juillet a été créée
autorisant le fait d'enlever le masque
dans les lieux clos de plus de 50
personnes dans les cinémas dans les
théâtres là où le masque est pourtant
indispensable a avancé que c'est l'été
il fait chaud on a plus de mal à
supporter le mas mais c'est quand même
indispensable de le conserver dans les
lieux clos parce que c'est là où ont
lieu les contaminations y compris dans
les ascenseurs il ya un fort relâchement
là aussi on voit beaucoup de gens dans
les transports publics dans les
ascenseurs qui ont un masque mais sous
le nez est donc là vraiment ils prennent
et les prennent des risques
ce qui est très important également
c'est de se faire vacciner
quel que soit le vaccin quel que soit le
variante vous êtes protégé d'un passage
en réanimation depuis des semaines nous
ne voyons plus en réanimation des gens
vaccinés donc c'est vraiment très
important
faites le pour vous faites le pour votre
entourage vaccinez vous je reviens à ma
première question tu iras moquer ski
vous gêne dans l'application du pass
sanitaires bien vous zappez toutes
sortes d' incohérences de la part du
gouvernement
celle que je viens de signer sur le fait
de permettre d'enlever le mas dans les
lieux clos à fin à partir du moment où
vous avez votre pas sanitaire ce qui est
une fausse protection on vient de le
voir entre reportages ensuite nous
sommes quand même 1 face à un
gouvernement qui a sorti le fait que
dans la quarantaine obligatoire des gens
qui sont positifs
vous avez une autorisation de sortie de
deux heures par jour dans une
quarantaine obligatoire c'est grande et
unique au monde quoi soit vous êtes en
quarantaine et c'est une quarantaine
étanche mais dire vous pouvez sortir
deux heures par jour alors que vous êtes
contaminants qu'on le sait c'est
totalement n'importe quoi après la cnil
elle même a souligné tous les problèmes
d'atteinte particulièrement forte aux
libertés de deux 2 passes 1 et puis vous
avez de tout ce fichier qui est
désormais dans le pr dans la loi qui a
été votée par l'assemblée nationale
accessible à tous les policiers pour
permettre le le suivi de justement la
quarantaine alors que jusqu'à présent il
n'était accessible qu'aux corps médical
nous qu'il nous faudrait c'est vraiment
mettre le paquet sur les 5 millions de
personnes à risque qui ne sont pas
encore vaccinés les il vous avez un
million de plus de 75 ans un million de
gens qui ont entre 65 et 75 ans vous
avez beaucoup de personnes qui ont des
maladies chroniques qui ne sont pas
encore tous nous avec ciné par rapport à
la prévention dans les lieux scolaires
il faut d'urgence installées du
purificateur d'air dont chaque salle de
classe dans tous les réfectoires des
établissements scolaires mais également
des entreprises
tu as un moyen facile de se protéger de
limiter l'effet dollar y en a tiré un
mois également a été votée hier dans la
nuit la vaccination obligatoire d'aidés
soignants vous êtes de la profession
c'était une évidence selon vous oui pour
nous un soignant moral et déontologie à
se vacciner pour protéger les personnes
les plus fragiles et depuis le vous
aviez les chiffres santé publique france
au 20 mai qui indiquait que 91% des
professionnels de santé étaient vaccinés
donc on a été choqué de la campagne de
communication particulièrement ignoble
du gouvernement qui pendant les huit
jours à a montré du doigt les lys
régnant en faisant croire que nous
n'étions pas suffisamment vacciner en se
basant uniquement à dessein sur les
chiffres de médecine de santé au travail
des hôpitaux qui sont forcément
partielle parce que vous avez beaucoup
par exemple d'infirmières qui sont allés
dans des centres de vaccination comme
bénévole ou vacataires et qui en
profitait pour se faire vacciner
eux-mêmes sur place en ville mais cela
ne sont pas dans les chiffres et donc il
aurait il fallu faire un recensement au
niveau de tous les établissements de
santé pour voir qui est réellement
vaccinez vous par les chiffres de santé
publique france était dans la base de
santé ti nation parce qu'il y avait une
gazette vous professionnels de santé et
donc c'est important on a vu par exemple
une enquête du journal le monde est
parue dans le journal ni juillet qui
montrait que sur l'établissement paul
demers 2
l'ap-hp dans l'oise vous aviez trois
fois plus de vacciner ce qui est
enregistré normative de santé au travail
merci beaucoup vous tirez amour d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes à porte parole du
syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers merci beaucoup